(audience cheers)
- Since you were here a couple months ago,
you got an Oscar nomination.
We knew it was gonna happen.
(audience cheers)
Everyone knew it was gonna happen.
How did you find out?
That's really cool news.
- Watching the broadcast at home.
- Really?
- In the morning,
there was a knock at
the door of my bedroom,
and my kids were there with balloons
and they had a Carvel ice cream cake.
- Oh my God, I will cry right now.
That's so sweet.
- It was Fudgy the Whale.
- Aww, ice cream cakes are good.
- Oh yes.
- Yeah.
- Enjoyed that one.
And now it's a core memory of mine.
- I love that, I love it.
Are you getting prepared for a speech?
Do you prepare speeches or do
you, are you superstitious?
- Ooh, fail to prepare, prepare to fail.
- Oh, well, I'm the first one.
- I'm gonna put something, I'm
gonna put something in mind.
Keep it behind glass with
a little hammer on it,
in case of emergency.
- [Kelly] And you boop boop.
- And then I'll be able to
thank all the nice people.
- [Kelly] Okay, I like this.
- Help get me where I need to be.